hey guys i'm editing some videos right
now and i noticed that i am blown up
with comments to react the Deadpool 2
teaser trailer I'm not going to do it
because it actually debuted before Logan
and fears I saw the whole trailer and
the theaters and it was hilarious and
clever and brilliant and there's no way
i can ever faked my reaction to act like
I've never seen that before because why
would I want to do that and if I've
already seen it in the tray and the
theaters I'm not going to do it again at
home and pretend I haven't seen it so if
there's people who already saw Logan
online who are acting like that is the
first time seeing the trailer they're
probably liars and what they went
through one of those screenings where
there wasn't any trailers beforehand but
if they watch it in the actual cinema
plex they are probably faking their
reactions but yeah I really like the
trailer it's hilarious but sorry I just
I can't give you guys a fake reaction I
hope you understand